à regarder comme c'est sympa cette
petite lumière comme ça bon ça va vous
allez bien tout se passe bien regarder
de quoi on va parler aujourd'hui parler
de cet essaim de 7,35 là bas qu'il
arrive même plus à parler on va parler
de cette enceinte klein pas si vous y
connaissez en enceinte si vous y
connaissez en musique c'est une enceinte
de moi ou elle s'appelle la white sands
alors y avait eus en x qui était sorti
l'année dernière
là c'est là où est censé modèle un poil
plus petit mais avec un son mais avec un
son qui sonne vraiment bien voilà la
boîte alors fait voir ce qu'on a ici à
l'intérieur on retrouve ici
l'enceinte c'est pas mal du tout ça et
on le voit ici là regardez c'est écrit
elle a été co développé avec dévia l'ico
conçu avec des violets ici j'ai une
entrée auxiliaire jack 3 5
c'est mon alimentation qui est juste là
que câble qui peut venir passer là comme
ça ça va pas me la déstabiliser c'est
très joli ce que tu es tout noir comme
salal tissu sur le banc ya vraiment un
côté très très bien ensuite à
l'intérieur de la boîte qu'est-ce que
j'ai bloc d'alim huawei
je branche tac j'appuie il passe la tacc
j'ai plus qu'à brancher et là je vais
avoir ma carte de garantie ok ça marche
ça c'est mon guide de démarrage rapide
qui m'explique comment ça fonctionne et
ça c'est quoi ça ah c'est une petite
chiffre est parce qu effectivement je
l'ait remarqué ou que ici ça prend peu
les traces de doigts normalement c'est
un objet vous n'allez pas trop manipuler
mais si vous manipulez a dit vous avez
votre petite fille fait qui vient vous
la nettoyez ça c'est très très cool
alors à l'intérieur vous avez en vous
faire ou vous faire qui va être là pour
votre base pour meutre sont très très
grave le bouffeur il est orientée par le
maxi juste à l'intérieur ils vous avez
un petit système de push push ça là pour
vous envoyer des basses très rondes et
qui sonne mais vraiment mais vraiment
extrêmement bien branché sa world
je me connecte
[ __ ] la vache et du sont allés grave
c'est ouf
et c'est un bouffeur de 40 watts que
vous avez à l'intérieur il voudrait
retrouver tout autour à l'intérieur
cachés ici là sous la grille 3 twitter
les twitter c'est pour le son et gus et
twitter de 5 watts qui répartit de façon
complètement homogène pour venir vous
apporter un son à 360 degrés ce qui fait
que votre enceinte vous la prenez vous
la poser au milieu d'une pièce vous avez
retrouvé quand son à 360 degrés que vous
soyez d'un côté de l'autre vous
déplaciez ou pas vous avez du sang et du
très bon son laissons médiums aigus sont
très précis toutes les voies vont bien
se dégager c'est très très très précis
au niveau des aiguilles et vous avez
raison c'est rond d'or qui est
caractéristique
au niveau des sons graves au niveau des
basses c'est vraiment super bien alors
c'est très compliqué parce que bien
évidemment il fallait vous puissiez vous
venir l'écouter mais moi lorsque je
l'allumé je l'écouté j'étais vraiment
surpris tout de suite parce que tu es
basse ça ronronne mais vraiment vraiment
bien c'est grâce à différentes
technologies de davy aller
[Musique]
on dira connecter votre huawei centre
vous avez deux solutions soit vous allez
chercher directement dans votre
smartphone vous passez par le bluetooth
vous le trouvez vous êtes puis voilà et
ça marche très très bien
soit vous le prenez et grâce au nfc vous
venez le poser comme ça et lui il se
connecte directement le nfc en fait ça
passe par wes cherche pas si vous le
connaissez si vous en souvenez vous est
cher j'en ai déjà parlé notamment au
niveau des pc vous pouvez venir partager
directement depuis votre smartphone à
votre pc piloter votre pc grâce à votre
smartphone enfin cette techno de huawei
elle marche bien elle est intéressante
et voyez qu'on peut l'utiliser également
ici pour faire communiquer sur
smartphone de huawei avec son enceinte
connecter au web ce qui vient rajouter à
expérience utilisateur c'est pratique
c'est facile c'est sympa titif il ya une
technologie au niveau du woofer
s'appelle la technologie d via les
speakers active matching technologie sam
on va l'appeler comme ça et qui veut
dire travailler avec vos petits push
push sur les côtés
[Musique]
ce sont deux unités passive
vous y retrouvez d'un côté et de l'autre
qui sont alimentés par cette technologie
stan en grandvaux deux unités passive
d'un côté de l'autre elles vont venir
vibrer pour vous apporter vraiment cette
sensation de basse et ça c'est une
techno 100% des via les et c'est là où
on voit vraiment le l'expertisé vraiment
l' expertise du fabricant français
d'enceinte
il ya une autre fonctionnalité qui est
assez marrante si par exemple j'écoute
de la musique ici sur mon smartphone
voyez c'est julie coin sur le smartphone
et je veux bien transférer directement
et bien je viens de choses et jetons et
hop le belge fait la poser directement
leurs aînés c'est up et c'est de
connecter directement ici la musique
vient plus de la musique directement mon
empreinte donc ça c'est vachement
pratique en fait c'est un excellent
vachement cool ça permet de se connecter
de transférer facilement jeu proche de
pause et lorsque j'en ai marre d'écouter
de la musique live je le récupère et
dans mon téléphone je prends je pose
déjà kupper l'objectif magique non au
niveau des tweeters en trouve également
une technologie 2d vial et qui s'appelle
la dévia l'espèce qui va bien vous créer
un son complètement uniforme sans wang
comme on dit à 360 degrés quel que soit
l'endroit où vous allez vous situez où
ton l'enceinte il ya plusieurs façons de
le connecter notamment bluetooth et du
bluetooth 5.0 le codec séduit hell d'ac
et elle est également upnp universal
plug and play elle est certifiée à 13 24
bits 96 kg et hertz ici c'est pas du
high rise wireless cdu ars vous allez
pouvoir avoir par votre entrée jack
qu'on trouve un pavé de commandes fondre
dessus vous allez pouvoir venir goûter
ou des minutes et vous allez pouvoir
monter le son est ce que ça passe et que
vous le voyez au tournant regardez vous
avez sept petits voyants vous voyez
votre niveau
c'est très visuel et si vous voulez plus
vite pour le monter voulait s'appuyer là
sa bulle notre carrément vite sinon vous
il est comme ça un par un pour moi il ya
vraiment deux points négatifs ici la
toute première c'est qu'elle prend les
traces de doigts mais plus plus plus
plus plus dont vous avez avec la petite
fille fait vous permet de bien nettoyer
alors vous n'allez pas être tout le
temps dessus et comme vous êtes connecté
la plupart du temps en bluetooth vous
n'êtes pas bien vous mettre vos doigts
dessus et deuxième point négatif et vous
n'avez pas d'assistance vocale derrière
donc vous n'allez pas pouvoir venir la
piloter à la voir donc si vous voulez
une enceinte pilotable à la broye c'est
pas forcément celle ci qu'il vous faudra
mais si vous voulez une enceinte
connecter avec un son d extrêmement
bonne qualité ici c'est vraiment le gros
point positif
cet oiseau c'est la compacité ses leçons
immersif à tous
à 160° ses basses riches ces médiums
très juste ses aigus extrêmement précis
donc si vous voulez un très bel objet
avec un son de super bonne qualité bobby
sands ya aussi un truc qui est super
marrant pour venir couper la musique
lorsque vous l'écoutez la voyez là c'est
de la musique
si je viens la coupe et je pose la main
ça me fait un milieu direct et si je
veux bien la remettre la même manière je
pose ma main et la musique recommence
c'est une scène qui a été annoncé il ya
pas très longtemps qui coûte 179 euros
vous pouvez trouver en précommande à 149
euros soit 30 euros de remise
bon autant vous dire qu'ils voudraient
l'acheter je pense que c'est maintenant
qu'il faut le faire si vous êtes dans
l'écosystème de huawei si vous avez un
smartphone de huawei et que vous
utilisez bien évidemment les services de
huawei c'est une r5 qui va être
extrêmement intéressante toute la
technologie de nfc est super cool le son
est vraiment très très bon enfin moi
j'aime bien ce petit produit c'est une
vraie belle découverte
et je puis vous assurer en tout cas que
la qualité est là et il fut compliqué
quant au travers d'une vidéo mais je
peux vous assurer que la qualité audio
est vraiment au rendez vous donc ça
c'est vraiment super a vous de me dire
vous maintenant ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes déjà en recherche
d'une entente connectés qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette voie ou un sound
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter est-ce que vous avez déjà un
smartphone de huawei et si vous en avez
pas vous pouvez également qu'un plaisir
parce que cette enceinte là elle est
bien on se connecte en bluetooth très
facilement et ça c'est chouette sais pas
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
très rapidement
regardez-la sympa ce petit décor comme
ça moi vous trouvez pas mal regardé je
peux toucher s'interroger que le main
voilà c'est magnifique vous envoie
d'amour beaucoup d'amour ou des gros
bisou du lot à bientôt
l'apec
le temps
il